Let's go next to our caller from the six one
six area code who's calling today from six
one six.
Hey, David, am I on?
Yes, you are.
Who is this?
My name.
My name is.
John Paul, John time bomb or Michigan in I
just I just want to bring up a little bit
of an interesting thing I've been thinking
about for now.
Hold on.
Did you say your name is John Paul Jones?
Like the great basest.
No, don't the grateful isn't Led Zeppelin's
basis.
John Paul Jones.
Not I'm not and I I'm not sure at the time
most of Miller about that name, as John Paul
told the famous historical starer guy.
Okay, very good.
All right.
We'll go on.
I would just see I see about well, since about
three months ago, Jesse Ventura, now that
he was considering running for their Green
Party presidential nominee.
But it eventually did.
Or some sort of half.
He's a potential health problem.
He was forced to drop out.
But here's the thing.
I actually think the situation right now,
Al, it was so bad where we could use a Green
Party card that might actually stand a chance
this year.
And I'm thinking that if the green hollyhock
and so answers to the Green Party nominate
Jesse Ventura, assuming only is helpful, has
done well the way.
Wait a.
The Green Party may actually have a chance
to winning some states or are if things get
so bad, maybe even.
Even even the president say no.
So John Paul Jones, let me let me.
So there is absolutely no chance that a Green
Party candidate wins a single state.
There is no chance of that whatsoever.
Joe Biden is polling over 50 percent in a
huge number of states and nationally.
And really, the only thing a Green Party candidate
might do would be hand a state where it's
close to Donald Trump.
So a Green Party candidate would not win a
single state and they certainly would not
win the presidency at this point.
Oh, yeah.
OK.
Oh, that was good.
I was just think think about think you about
that because, you know, because things are
just so well I've still not been in the US
like right now that that's when things get
bad.
The bargain usually get desperate and.
And well, you know, yes, you're thinking about
all the right things.
Things are bad, but no, the Green Party in
this election could only potentially be a
major, major spoiler.
So let's slow.
Let's let's let's get Trump out of there.
Let's get Joe Biden in.
That's the next step.
All right.
Thank you, my friend.
I appreciate the call.
We're going to go to a very brief break.
It's going to feel so short, but then we'll
be back with more phone calls.
So please don't hang up if you are on hold,
because we are going directly back to the
phones.